angst vor pleitewelle
die bundesregierung stellt wegen der
umsatzeinbrüche in der krise hilfen für
hoteliers und restaurantbetreiber in
aussicht schwere vorwürfe gegen china
us-präsident trump beschuldigt das land
wegen der weltweiten ausbreitung des
corona virus und droht mit konsequenzen
mit einem virtuellen megakonzert sammeln
welt stars spenden aus dem homeoffice
für die helfer der korona pandemie
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
unserem nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag
dem tag bevor morgen wieder etliche
geschäfte öffnen dürfen
nicht so jedoch gaststätten und hotels
dableiben tische und betten weiter leer
von lockerungen in der kuba krise ist
die branche bislang ausgeschlossen
doch nun stellt die bundesregierung
hilfe in aussicht unklar ist nur wie die
konkret aussehen wird und wann sie kommt
vom stillstand zur insolvenz für viele
unternehmen wohl nur eine frage der zeit
der hotel und gaststättenverband dehoga
jedenfalls spricht von
milliardenverlusten und warnt von den
rund 223.000 betrieben in deutschland
ruhe jedem dritten die pleite über den
hilferuf der gastronom andreas ruppert
hier geht seit fünf wochen nichts mehr
kein bowling billard es wird nichts
gegessen nichts getrunken das potsdamer
bowlingcenter ist nicht zum ersten mal
seit 20 jahren ich habe seit 20 jahren
jeden tag auf und das ist ja wirklich
null auf null gefahren also ich hab zu
ich habe einfach zu ich bin einzel
kaufmann ich habe keinerlei einnahmen ja
und das gab es bis jetzt noch nicht so
wie jörg bartel geht es den meisten in
der branche restaurants cafés kneipen
bars und clubs sind geschlossen das
corona virus hat dem gastronomie und
hotelgewerbe den wirtschaftlichen boden
unter den füßen weggerissen
der branchenverband stellt forderungen
erstens muss ab dem tag der
wiedereröffnung die reduzierte
mehrwertsteuer eingeführt werden für
gastronomische umsätze zweitens muss ein
rettungsfonds geschaffen werden wo die
betriebe direkte finanzhilfen vom staat
erhalten das in der vergangenheit auch
anderen branchen schon zugutegekommen
konkrete hilfen die verspricht die
politik nicht bundesfinanzminister
scholz sagt per zeitungsinterview
natürlich schauen wir genau ob und wo
wir gezielt weitere hilfen benötigen
dabei haben wir vor allem jene branchen
im blick für die ihr so schnell noch
nicht wieder los geht das hotel und
gaststättengewerbe gehört sicherlich
dazu
und auch schleswig holsteins
ministerpräsident ist zurückhaltend
ich denke wir dürfen auch nicht zu viel
in diesen zeiten versprechen dass wir
auf der einen seite jetzt viele hilfen
zahlen und am anderen ende dann sagen
dass ganz viele steuersenkungen danach
kommen wir werden das was wir im moment
machen auch bezahlen müssen konkretes
also gibt's noch nicht für jörg bartel
und all die anderen aus der hotel und
gastro branche zählt eigentlich nur eine
frage wann dürfen wir wieder öffnen
ab morgen ändern sich einige chor ohne
regeln in deutschland so dürfen
geschäfte mit einer einkaufs fläche von
bis zu 800 quadratmetern in den meisten
bundesländern wieder öffnen
besonders viel ändert sich ab montag in
sachsen da sind dann auch wieder
gottesdienste erlaubt im kleinen rahmen
mit bis zu 15 personen beim einkaufen
muss jeder einen mund nasen schutz
tragen auch im bus und in der bahn
außerdem sollen hier die ersten schulen
wieder aufmachen
mehr dazu von stefan kern haus gymnasium
dresden die schulleiterin hat den
empfangstresen aufgebaut wir werden
morgen allerdings erstmal nur lehrer
anstehen und mit masken und
desinfektionsmitteln ausgestattet ab
dienstag dann können schüler kommen zu
konsultationen für die anstehenden
prüfungen schule wieder zu öffnen war
richtig findet die schulleiterin
es ist ganz ganz viele schul
organisatorisch möglich sicherlich mit
herausforderungen sicherlich mit
einschränkungen mit personal was vor ort
vielleicht hier und da auch mal mehr
eingesetzt werden kann oder auch
infrastrukturellen grenzerfahrungen aber
es ist möglich sachsen war rigoroser als
andere bundesländer bei kontakt
beschränkungen und total schließungen
nun dürfen kirchen wieder öffnen der
haken es dürfen nur 15 gläubige in die
kirche
das mag auf dörfern sinnvoll und machbar
sein aber nicht in einer stadt wie
dresden meint der frauenkirchenpfarrer
diese regel ist nicht für die
frauenkirche und nicht für die city
kirchen geschaffen sondern es ist eine
möglichkeit des christen wieder
zusammenkommen könnten vielleicht gibt
es ja auch die eine oder andere weitere
locker
im moment bleibt die frauenkirche in den
nächsten tagen noch geschlossen
und noch eins macht sachsen im
alleingang mundschutz pflicht in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln sowie das
bislang schon für wochenmärkte
vorgeschrieben war
ich finde die meisten pflicht ist
unbedingt notwendig und es hätte auch
schon viel eher kommen müssen diese
mundschutz pflicht wird nun ausgeweitet
sie gilt auch für baumärkte und alle
anderen läden die nun erstmals ab morgen
in sachsen wieder öffnen dürfen
und so haben sich corona
infektionszahlen in deutschland
entwickelt stand 18 uhr 30 sind laut
johns hopkins universität mehr als 100
44.000 infektionen durch tests bestätigt
davon gelten 88.000 menschen als genesen
4547 starben in verbindung mit dem virus
aktuelle zahlen und entwicklungen zur
corona pandemie haben wir auch jederzeit
in unserer heute app dort finden sie
auch eine nachrichten ticker sowie
weitere grafiken und statistiken
unterdessen ist in zwischen den usa und
china ein streit darüber entbrannt wer
für das virus verantwortlich ist im netz
kursiert schon länger die theorie nicht
der bild tiermarkt dem chinesischen yuan
sei die quelle der pandemie sondern das
dortige viren forschungsinstitut dass
die größte wären bank asiens beherbergt
den verdacht patient null könnte ein
mitarbeiter des forschungslabors sein
greift jetzt präsident trump auf und
kündigt vorsorglich konsequenzen an
el materi ein chinesisches labor als
wahlkampf waffe in den usa trump
freundliche moderatoren geben china die
schuld an der pandemie werfen joe biden
und angeblich linken medien fotoshow vor
ausgelöst all das auch durch
ermittlungen der us geheimdienste ob das
virus ursprünglich aus dem chinesischen
militär labor in buch
entkam die chinesische führung ließ den
direktor nun im staatsfernsehen
auftreten von apple keine chance dass
dieses virus von uns kamen wir haben
strenge regeln für unsere forschung
deshalb sind wir so sicher herr jörn
sieht sich als ziel einer kampagne
keiner seiner mitarbeiter habe sich
versehentlich infiziert und hier würden
auch keine bio waffen entwickelt nach
allem was ich über virologie weiß gibt
es keinerlei beleg dass irgendetwas an
diesem virus künstlich hergestellt wurde
aber donald trump zweifelt an den zahlen
aus china gleichzeitig preis der noch
mal den 250 milliarden dollar handelt
stil mit china vielleicht wirkt er
deshalb zurückhaltender als sonst zum
ursprung des virus wenn es ein fehler
war es eben ein fehler
aber wenn sie es bewusst gemacht haben
sollte es konsequenzen geben
was im labor von johann genau geschah
das soll nun die amerikanischen
geheimdienste herausbekommen denn allen
anderen traut die us regierung dicht vor
75 jahren wurden konzentrationslager in
ganz deutschland durch die alliierten
befreit
eigentlich waren festakte mit tausenden
von gästen geplant aber wegen der korona
pandemie gab es die gedenkfeier nur in
kleinem rahmen
in bergen-belsen gedachten
niedersachsens ministerpräsident stephan
weil und vertreter jüdischer gemeinden
heute in einem stillen festakt der opfer
mehr als 72.000 menschen starben in
bergen belsen unter ihnen auch anne
frank weltweit haben millionen orthodoxe
christen unter dem eindruck der korona
pandemie ihr osterfest gefeiert
im bulgarischen sofia fand die
mitternachtsmesse im freien statt
so konnten die gläubigen an der
zeremonie teilnehmen
in der christ erlöser kathedrale in
moskau feierte der russische patriarch
kirill
mit nur wenigen geistlichen in russland
gelten wegen der pandemie strenge
ausgangssperren
das spannendste bei videokonferenzen ist
ja oft gar nicht was gesagt wird sondern
der hintergrund ganz neue einblicke in
leben und wohnen der kollegen seit heute
nacht wissen wir aber auch wie es bei
elton john im garten aussieht oder
welche tapete taylor swift bevorzugt den
popstar lady gaga hat jetzt gezeigt wie
man aus dem homeoffice ein mega ereignis
macht im netz musik und appelle um
spenden zu sammeln im kampf gegen die
pandemie david sauer mit den highlights
lächeln auch wenn dein herz zerbricht
mit einem mutmacher song eröffnet lady
gaga und die stars der welt folgen
taylor swift mal ohne lichtshow und
perfekten sound in einer art home office
für superstars
[Musik]
stevie wonder mit viel gefühl und sir
elton john haut im garten in die tasten
oktober
ihre baxi zwischen den gigs erklären
nicht nur musiker worum es geht
danksagung an alle die die welt und das
leben am laufen halten
auch von gleich zwei ehemaligen first
lady ein abend voll musik für alle und
jeden von der 18-jährigen billy irish
die einen klassiker haucht bis zu den
rolling stones mit zusammen über 300
jahren nicht auf einer bühne aber
trotzdem als eine band die bilanz des
virtuellen super star treffs acht
stunden bestes entertainment und fast
130 millionen dollar spenden für
hilfsorganisationen die gegen die
pandemie kämpfen
[Musik]
tolle sache toll finden sicher auch
viele das anhaltend schöne wetter auch
wenn es natürlich viel zu trocken ist
so bleibt es auch morgen sonnig nur im
äußersten süden und im nordosten zeigen
sich einige wolken bei lebhaftem ostwind
werden 15 bis 23 grad an den küsten 11
bis 16 grad erreicht
das war es von uns schön dass sie wieder
dabei waren das heute journal mit
marietta slomka zur gewohnten zeit um
drei viertel 10 und morgen freut sich
christian sievers an dieser stelle auf
sie ich sage tschüss und gebe weiter an
berlin direkt und theo koll